After years of trying, the tech industry
is finally making robots happen. From
vacuuming to mowing to serving drinks
and patrolling airports.
These autonomous droids are everywhere.
And yes, they're a little creepy.
But then there's this little guy,
the Gitamini.
It's designed and programmed to be
paired with a human.
Sort of like a very obedient dog full of
ones and zeros. It also carries stuff for
you, 20 pounds of stuff, making it a proxy
backpack or kind of like a grocery bag
on wheels.
If you trace Gita's family tree,
eventually you arrive at the Vespa.
A few years ago, Piaggio, the Italian
scooter giant, was looking for a product
to crack the American market, which
never really warmed up to the Vespa. And
invested in a Boston startup called FastForward
and the Gita project was born.
According to CEO Greg Lynn,
the idea was to zig where other robot
startups were zagging. Instead of trying
to replace the human entirely,
they set out to augment one. The Gita,
like a Vespa, was intended to replace car
trips, but by enabling walkable errands,
say going to the corner store for a bag
of dog food.
The bot's good for the person, and
indirectly it's good for the planet.
Still, these aren't the droids a lot of
people are looking for.
Piaggio hasn't said how many they've
sold, and they've acknowledged that the
Gita at ,850 has yet to really take over a
city or a whole neighborhood.
The larger opportunity lies in
commercial applications.
The company is now shifting to B2B
and trying to sell to airports,
construction sites, industrial areas and
clients like that.
Basically, anywhere you see a cart is
is ripe terrain for a Gita. When palling
around with a Gita, you're sure to
attract a whole parade of gobsmacked
onlookers.
That's the goal of this thing.
But until the general population is
totally unimpressed, follower bots like
the Gita still have a lot of work to
do.